what's up everyone welcome back to the
cinema center at marble for more
collider Tiff 2023 interviews I'm lucky
enough to be sitting with the team
behind the queen of my dreams
congratulations One of a Kind film
you do so many things in this movie I
can't wait to dig into a lot of it but
most of our audience will not know what
your film is just yet I'm sure you're
doing this a lot while you're at Tiff
would you mind giving a brief synopsis
of the film yeah the film
um is a story of a mother-daughter the
mother and daughter have a strained
relationship when the father slash
husband dies in Pakistan the daughter
has to go back to Pakistan for the
burial and it's through that trip to
Pakistan that we experience
um her and her mother's life through a
series of flashbacks both going to
Pakistan in the 60s and Nova Scotia
Sydney Nova Scotia in the 80s so it
takes place in three time periods two
countries uh it's a dramedy uh I
wouldn't say it's a Mama D uh but maybe
you know what I'm saying I'm gonna
repeat that term yeah I love it uh first
feature as a director which is a very
very big deal right I mean really
applaud for that it's an a big
accomplishment there so when you wake up
one day you say I want to direct my very
first feature film what did you think
was the first step to making that happen
to getting a film a green light and now
having done it would you recommend that
to another aspiring director out there
or did you find something more effective
along the way I mean basically the five
questions you just asked have like I
have a habit of that get ready there's
so much sort of like creative trauma in
that it's like who am I what do I do
what is my path
um but I will say that it was three
years ago when I was in the Tiff writers
Studio at the Bell light box
um doing that program and I was
surrounded by a bunch of other writer
directors with this screenplay or a
version of this screenplay and I was
still searching for a director a queer
Muslim Brown director and they were like
I think it's you and I made the decision
there to direct this film and to claim
that space for myself and so it's kind
of cool to come back full circle and
have the film be here
um I do think that I recommend maybe
your first feature that you direct be in
one country
uh maybe you know I mean it works for us
but like I have this incredible uh
superhero of a cast and incredible
producers and a team but maybe one
country uh a few locations
um exteriors night exterior night one
place one house and also I was so lucky
to like my wife slash producer said um
let's get it funded in Canada so I was
like how do you do that so that was the
beginning as well I am gonna make them
sing your Praises we'll get to all of
your incredible work uh soon but
remember I'll come your ways first
because we were just talking about Nita
before and you just seem to know what
you're looking for in a first time
feature filmmaker so do the two of them
have any shared qualities that signal to
you like yes they can direct a feature
film but also they'll be good
collaborators for me as well yes
I think I got that sense from Falls I
put um I I put my career life slash life
in her hands uh for this uh I think I
think we
this was something that I hadn't done
for a while so I didn't really know I
mean I don't usually know what I'm doing
but you know there's a little bit of a
familiarity to uh and it was but I think
as soon as I read the script and talked
to first from the beginning it felt like
we'd known each other for years and that
she knew what she was doing and whatever
she was doing I was I was in it
um and uh
it's it's been wonderful it's grown
whatever that whatever that was has
grown it's it's grown uh it's we've all
grown yes I will continue to build on
that and toss another question to the
two of you now because I have a very
good feeling this is only the first of
many directing efforts from you so what
is something about fazia that you are
really excited for more actors to get to
experience when they work together in
the future there was something amazing
about fazi on set is that
she knew how to command a space where I
find a lot of sometimes
female directors were still trying to
find a space and be recognized as
Leaders or the boss without be
considering bossy
um and she had a beautiful way in a
completely different country of getting
everybody to listen to her without their
egos coming up and I think that's very
hard to do
um
and she didn't try to do that she just
was doing that and that type of
leadership I think is commendable for
female directors right now I don't mean
to cut you off but I want to follow up
on that I feel like there might not be
an easy answer but how do you do that
what it what is the secret sauce what
would you say to another female director
out there who wants to be able to create
that same kind of space and command on a
film well I think that um and maybe it's
for all directors like there's this idea
that to be a leader you have to treat
people poorly you have to be abusive to
be taken seriously and that's just not
right and it's not true
um I think that the way that we can get
people to be with us is through kindness
and listening and compassion and you can
lead in a way that is not aggressive and
that's I think that's the future and if
that comes from some sort of you know
feminine power then then hell yeah but
but I do think that um you know it's
it's a changing of of how we think of
the system and the set and uh
and what it means to be a director okay
I'll come back your way with the
original question can you follow that up
and add more to this yeah there was uh
this this the audacity to have you know
your first feature be such a personal
story and just to go for it and then to
decide to all right we're gonna
all of it's gonna be on location in
Halifax and it's going to be on location
in Karachi all of it's going to be that
and to do that with as much
not it's it it was an enthusiasm it was
this sort of
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna put you on
blast it was that do you remember that
day at the house where we got sick
so so
um for anybody who's used to traveling
to uh that part of the world like you
get sick it just happens like you're
gonna go there you're gonna get sick
um and
I saw fazia Direct
laughs
lying down
with blankets and pillows on set in the
heat
you know all like all the runs runny
nose runny XYZ and just in between takes
just being like yeah no that was that
was pretty good but we go again we could
do better than that cool than you but
and then you'd walk in be like hey how
are you doing like great living the
dream you know and it and it was it's
that it's that mentality that I feel
like gets the job done I feel like
there's
like I've said this before I got in
trouble for saying it before but there's
a lot of young filmmakers don't
understand and don't respect the amount
of time that it takes to get good at
something
and there's this entitlement to be just
like well just because it took you 15 20
years doesn't mean it shouldn't I'm just
like no you can get an opportunity
tomorrow but to be ready for an
opportunity to come up and to see fazia
Direct in Pakistan under those
circumstances that is the previous 10 15
20 years of work for that moment to be
able to execute that you know and and I
think a lot of people don't know like
well I'll learn on the job yeah and
you'll learn and then you'll get
opportunities and you won't be ready for
those opportunities and as a result your
product will reflect that
and that will reflect the these people
who give opportunities to first-time
filmmakers and future filmmakers they'll
see that
that they shouldn't be funding
first-time filmmakers if they're
unprepared
so to see fazia so prepared to take that
challenge is a boon to anybody trying to
do that but you have to follow the
amount of work ethic not what she's
getting out of it well and I think
there's something that I mean off of
that like the idea that
you know women are risky as directors or
there's risk in like you know a certain
kind of person whether it's a queer
person or a person of color or a woman
and or trans person or a non-binary
director and truthfully uh that that's
just not true you know it it is so much
it's about
um like life experience can matter
maturity can matter sure and what you've
done before matters and I think this
idea of who should have those
opportunities
um is also something that you know we
need to reevaluate and look at also I
think it's that combination of humility
plus knowing what you want
um and I think that she knows very
clearly what she wants but I think that
it feels it feels on set it feels like
we're all going to go and find out what
we want together so I think there's a
there's that element that that sort of
trick magicians think that she has as
well which I feel makes us all believe
that we're doing this we we came up with
this
um but but it's you know what you want
but there's there's the humility that I
felt um I I saw it in the film last
night I saw it for the first time and I
I don't know why that word just kept
coming back to me that there's a there's
a humility in the way that we're seeing
these people I also feel like you can't
make a movie like this without having a
Clear Vision and knowing exactly what
you want so everything comes together so
that definitely shines through in the
finished film all right I'll come to you
now kind of to build on this idea I
guess of using experience to deliver
really good work correct me if I'm wrong
I believe this is your first lead role
in a major feature film which is very
good very very ambitious project to do
that with of all of the past number ones
on the call sheet that you've worked
with is there anyone you found yourself
trying to emulate in terms of how you
carried yourself on set as a leader and
also tackled a significant role in a
film oh my God there's so many
um
I'm a part of this acting class that's
just phenomenal and we go to the same
acting class and
so lucky to be working on this film with
the same coach doing the work we love to
do
and
there's a specific actress two specific
actors that I always think about and
they're acting Gabrielle Graham and
Augustus Michael and they're fine actors
and
what I love about their work is they
play for the real
and that was my goal I struggled a lot I
was scared going into the film because
there were so many things that I wanted
to be true that I hadn't looked at
enough in my life so this was a call to
action looking at sexuality looking at
abuse generational abuse looking at my
connection to my homeland all these
things I was I kind of looked at and I
still haven't fully looked at them so if
I was to do the film all over again
maybe today or six months down the line
I would go even further in the
insecurities and the love of all those
things other than that I'm a big fan of
Adam Driver Kate Winslet Viola Davis but
also Amal Clooney how she carries
herself so all those four people
constantly stay with me as well while
I'm working good names to up yeah and
can I just add that the thing that I
felt like I could do or part of my job
was remind Amrit that who she is is in
both of the characters like she already
is Maryam and she already is Ezra
um and just to trust that I'm gonna make
everyone sing your Praises now because
first lead role in a feature film I
think it's going to be the first of many
so can each of you tell me something
about Amrit that you are excited for
more directors out there to get to
experience when they work with her as a
lead yeah I think that you know the
thing that struck me when I met Amrit on
a uh on a zoom we we Zoom auditioned the
first time and then we met in person
um it was this spark and and when she is
in
she is all in
and not just a hundred percent it's like
add three zeros to that which I don't
even know I'm terrible at math so I
don't know what that equals but a lot
it's a lot it's a lot of percent
um but there's no halfway and so when
you're looking to you know when you come
in and you're you're the one who's like
this is my project I'm obsessed with
this I've been working on this for so
many years you want people who are
willing to go there with you and be
there with you and hold your hand and
you're like we're diving in underwater
for a while we might not be able to
breathe for a second but you're with me
right you trust me and she trusts you
and um I I can't wait for more people to
experience that
thanks for us and now how how about for
the two of you as scene Partners one of
my family
stress the interview
ing about her as a scene partner that
you appreciated this woman here is
um
studying together for what like six
seven years now
um
she's absolutely ruthless when it comes
to acting like it is the thing that she
has dedicated her life to in a way that
I haven't seen anybody approach it she I
like I love her dearly and I can't stand
her all she like all she talks about is
acting all the time it is the only thing
that is on her mind like to the point
where like I feel like she's not a real
person you know what I mean she's just
this absolute ball of excitement and
love for the art form and for somebody
who like you know I I feel like I I give
to it as well but then I'm just like I
like to
just like to turn it off for a bit
sometimes and you can't do that around
her it's just who she is
and I think that that is such a like
a blessing to any story any director any
scene partner for somebody to be just
like no we're not done we're still doing
this and we're gonna go again and we're
gonna go again and we're gonna go again
regardless of what the like emotional
cost is because it's worth it for the
artistic result or the artistic process
rather
um
I see her dedicate herself to this
character and to her craft and to those
things
and there is no way it's not a benefit
to anybody who chooses to pay attention
to that as what she's doing like her
approach to that so any filmmaker any
actor anybody on that set will benefit
from you know the the lifetime and the
and the filmography that Amrit core is
going to be
participating in for the next 20 30 40
years
I'm gonna clip that out I'm gonna send
it to you and you send it to every every
you want to work on
is my demo reel oh my God what a
beautiful answer
um no
um I
so you know in in in in our line of work
sometimes you show up and you want to do
the work uh but you think that the work
is easy you know how to do the work uh
you're going to be able to get it done
and
nothing will make you hugely
uncomfortable but I think that with
Amrit I felt also it was the
relationship we were playing uh we
didn't get a chance to rehearse together
at all but I felt that when we work
together
there was a lot of stuff that she tries
to stir up she creates a lot of
discomfort
um and the discomfort you don't realize
how valuable that discomfort is because
you know at the time that it's happening
it's it's uncomfortable but I'm really
I'm really grateful that you that you
did that and that was really I think it
it was amazing and I saw again when I
saw it and and I knew that you know
because sometimes you don't know it's
like I think you want to play for real
yeah so you sort of blur and in my head
I know that okay real acting whatever
but I think you blurred it all up and
made it all just really mixed up and
that was great I loved it I feel like
you're gonna be floating through the
rest of this Festival now see you
mentioned that you two didn't get to
rehearse together what about when it
came to figuring out how you were
essentially going to be playing the same
character because like different parts
of her life but there has to be some
sort of connective tissue to make her
feel cohesive I think uh we did so I I
shot a lot of stuff before she did for
the for the movie
um and I was playing with her younger
self Ayana Manji
um I think you watched a lot of this
stuff uh I was very uncomfortable with
that
especially because I didn't get to see
her stuff and then you know try to do
her before so but she and and then you
told me that you watched some of my
stuff on YouTube which made me really
upset
like Pakistani dramas yes like why did
you watch that I didn't watch it but
anyway but I think it's I think it's
Instinct it's because we were both
playing Mariam and we knew what that
character was I think we I mean
she made sure that we knew what she was
I think we both played Mariam
are we and but there was a Mariam in
both of us so it worked you feel it
while you're watching this I have so
many questions I'm not allowed to keep
you here all day I really wanted to ask
this one in particular because part of
the reason why I'm so obsessed with with
films and all forms of Storytelling is
because often I have an easier time
processing like my own truths via those
stories and I love the way that you
explore this situation kind of via film
in this movie so for each of you can you
name a specific film that you know was
very influential in terms of seeing
yourself in it or maybe it coming into
your life at just the right time that
helped you with something in your
day-to-day yeah absolutely I'll go this
one
um I was 18 years old and I watched this
movie called The Fall by tarsome Singh
and uh and it was
the the level of Storytelling in that
movie The amount of time it took him I
think he spent 19 years making the movie
and I think it was something like 10
years shooting it over all these places
it was just
I didn't know it at the time when I was
watching it but there's a scene where
they're filming underwater and there's a
shot where they swoop under an elephant
while five people are swimming around it
because one of them couldn't swim
and it's a diversity of characters these
locations and at that moment I went I
will do anything I can to be a part of
the industry that makes something like
that happen
and I didn't have any technical skills
I'm like I don't know how to write I
don't know how to direct what do you do
I'm like are you good at public speaking
all right acting it is you know
um and that was like the shift where I
was I didn't exactly know but I wanted
to contribute to this art form uh and
that was a huge thing for as far as like
up one particular moment in watching
film that made that happen for me and
then and then
you know 15 years later here we are true
Masterpiece right there great pick
I haven't watched that one I'll have to
watch it it's incredible I will
absolutely watch it like four days ago
again like it's so good
um for me it was a movie called Fire by
deepametta
um I it was the
I had suspicions that I wanted to act
and I wasn't sure even when I went into
theater school I wasn't sure I actually
want to talk but when I saw that film I
was so blown away about the ballsiness
to tell a queer story and and the
sexuality of two Indian women and the
age difference and the fact that
vipametta went over the hill to tell
that story in spite of all the
controversy and the backlash the bullets
that's a very hard thing to do and
I saw that and I said I want to be a
part of the type of Storytelling that
wires different changes the wiring of
people and the way they think so then I
decided to continue it's going on my
list now
God okay no one is enough yeah
knows her answer is going to be buyer
like it's going to be so good so she's
just like y'all go ahead
I'm about to shut it down out there
um I'm sorry this is such a hard
question for me to answer but I've just
been thinking of The Big Lebowski that
was but I don't know what that means but
that was it's my whenever someone asks
me that's that's the film because I've
seen it so many times and I love it so
much and I think I think the reason that
I love it is
is that uh no it's I I don't know the
reason that I love it but I think it's
the Stillness of that main character
which I really love I think mine is like
I feel like the film that I have to talk
about uh is that was part of making this
movie uh you know just one of the touch
points and in some ways was uh the
Farewell by Lulu Wong and you know I
watched that film I didn't watch it at
Sundance but I watched in like one of
the awards screenings in Los Angeles uh
by Sundance and afterwards I went up to
you know Kim yutani from Sundance who's
you know one of the head programmers and
she was like how did you like it and I
said that movie
um I I think we all when you're an Asian
kid or you know a parent of immigrants
you all dream of telling your story
that is somewhere in the world of the
farewell and so um yeah that that movie
was deeply impactful to me I will say
huge congratulations on the queen of my
dreams thank you for sharing your
passion for the craft with us too and
then to everybody out there watching
keep an eye out for this movie you do
not want to miss it and stay tuned we'll
have more from tip 2023 for you very
soon